los asteroides que existen por cientos
de miles en el sistema solar son los
remanentes que quedaron de la formación
de nuestro sistema planetario por ende
estudiarlos nos ayuda a comprender cada
vez más cómo se formó el sistema solar y
por lo tanto nuestros propios planetas
de todos esos asteroides los asteroides
troyanos son asteroides que comparten la
órbita de júpiter es decir a medida que
júpiter gira alrededor del sol
esos asteroides troyanos giran alrededor
del sol en un gran conjunto por delante
de él y en otro conjunto por detrás de
él en su camino orbital esta sonda
espacial luz y lo que hará por vez
primera es estudiar ese sistema de
asteroides bueno y para entender que
nuestra audiencia entienda esto cómo
impacta sus vidas personales qué pasaría
si la nasa descubre cómo se formaron los
planetas en nuestra vida diaria
bueno por supuesto que el derrotero
humano en lo que es el conocimiento del
universo
existe desde la misma existencia de la
humanidad siempre nos vamos a preguntar
de dónde venimos hacia dónde vamos
quiénes somos el lugar que ocupamos en
el en el cosmos el estudio del sistema
solar es básicamente el estudio de
nuestro barrio de nuestra ciudad en lo
que es en términos astronómicos
entender la formación del sistema solar
como comentaba antes es entender mejor
cómo es nuestro propio planeta y eso
tiene un impacto fundamental en todo lo
que tiene que ver por ejemplo con el
comportamiento de nuestro planeta en
términos físicos en términos
digamos geodinámicos y el cambio el
cambio ambiental que se está produciendo
en gran medida todo ese conocimiento
redunda en creces en lo que es la vida
del ser humano y señor bagú explíquenos
que tan única es esta misión usted cree
que ha habido algo así y similar antes
es la primera vez a ver no es la primera
vez que se estudian asteroides pero si
es la primera vez que se estudian este
tipo de asteroides y la primera vez que
una nave va a visitar tantos asteroides
en particular luz y está programada para
que a lo largo de sus 12 años de vida si
visité siete asteroides en total de
estudiar estos asteroides es fundamental
porque hay muchas dudas respecto a cómo
se formaron los planetas y sobre todo el
lugar en el que se formaron hay una
teoría de un par de décadas que cada vez
cobra más valor que es la migración
planetaria que de alguna manera explica
que los planetas que hoy en día están en
los lugares que ocupan wheater saturno
por ejemplo en el pasado remoto no se
encontraban en esos lugares sino que se
habían formado en otra región del
sistema solar estudiar estos satélites
troyanos de estos asteroides perdón
troyanos de júpiter nos va a permitir
confirmar o avanzar en esa confirmación
o no respecto de el lugar en el que se
formaron los grandes planetas del
sistema solar
y brevemente siete asteroides en 12 años
esto de 12 años es habitual para las
exploraciones espaciales o no tanto
si es habitual es habitual porque el
recorrido que
conllevan estas misiones semiautomáticas
estos robots tenemos que aclarar
obviamente mucho ustedes lo saben no son
sondas espaciales que van tripuladas son
básicamente robots que trabajan de
manera semi automática para llegar a
destino comienzan a girar alrededor del
sol y se van entre comillas tomando de
la gravedad de los planetas para poder
ir avanzando y llegar finalmente a
destino por ende es muy común que tarden
una década o un poquito más incluso
grano solamente para llegar sino para
finalizar toda la misión gracias señor
vago por su información